you might remember the beginning of it's
a wonderful life right Jimmy Stewart's
behind the counter there's a panic in
the community people show up and they
want their money and what does Jimmy
Stewart have to tell him he doesn't have
it well I'm sorry my gave your money to
marry no I don't have it right real-life
bank runs are seldom unprovoked they're
almost always runs that are in trouble
on banks that are in trouble beforehand
that have been badly managed that their
loans are not performing artificially
low interest rates stimulates a boom
which inevitably leads to a bust as
Mises and Hayek say and that's why
fractional reserve banking is inherently
destabilizing you show me a bank in
crisis I'll show you bad regulations not
just fractional reserves takes more than
that to cause a crisis how does a bank
is supposed to make money if it's not
allowed to take your you know pay you a
low interest rate for your checking
account deposit and lend it out to
someone else at a higher you can earn
the spread if you don't let banks do
that well then they would go out of
business why would there be banks okay
so that's not correct welcome to this
eighth debate of the so of the second
season of the solo forum both to those
in our physical audience at the
sub-culture theater in downtown
Manhattan and to the thousands around
the globe who are watching us on live
streaming we are a monthly debate series
that features topics of special interest
to libertarians and aims to enhance
social and professional ties within New
York City's libertarian community this
is an Oxford style debate in which the
audience initially votes for against or
undecided on the resolution and then
again after the debate is over whoever
moves the vote in his or her favor
is declared the winner go into solo vote
calm to cast your initial vote you'll
find the tonight's resolution reads
fractional reserve banking poses a
threat to the stability of market
economies arguing on the affirmative for
the affirmative on the resolution we
have economist Robert Murphy Bob please
come to the stage
[Applause]
opposing the resolution we have
economist George Celgene George please
come to the stage
it is it is technically true that Jorge
joined the Cato Institute a few years
ago and Bob has been with the Mises
Institute although he's done other
things with his life too so it is sort
of Mises again skater guys take a chair
then we have a resolution called
fractional reserve banking poses a
threat to the stability of market
economies Jane please close the voting
Bob please take the podium and defend
the resolution fractional reserve
banking poses a threat to the stability
of market economies take it away Bob
thank you everyone for coming out I
realized this dave was speaking here
that I can now truthfully say that one
time I played a club in New York City
and Dave Smith open for me so I'm happy
to be able to say that also I don't
understand what the project for what
it's worth I have plenty of small
Mexican guys who love my work and they
come up and it's never been confusing
for me so David I should talk more all
right
the resolution tonight is a bit
technical and I've been encouraged I'm
gonna take some of my time in this
opening statement to define some terms
but I promise for those of you who are
deep in this literature by the end of
this you know I will give George chance
to respond of course and will and I will
address like his very subtle points but
here I can't assume people know even
some of these basic terms so let me
define things from the start the first
distinction we need to keep in mind is
the difference between like the base
money that whatever is serving is the
actual money in the economy so in our
economy of course that's dollar bills
versus claims on the base money that
commercial banks issue okay and what's
going to end up being significant and
this is the whole point of why
fractional reserve banking is
destabilizing or threatens financial
stability is that in most day-to-day
transactions those two things both can
serve effectively as money that a
merchant doesn't distinguish between
someone if something cost ten dollars
and you try to give them this they'll
take it or if you have a debit card and
swipe it and
what that's of course saying is a
commercial bank is telling the merchants
no no we have $10 this this guy's good
for it go ahead and sell them the thing
for $10 or if you write a personal check
historically commercial banks also
issued pieces of paper that were claims
like tickets issued by the bank that
were called bank notes that was also
effectively what it was was saying
somebody who goes to the bank with this
ticket is legally entitled to the
underlying base money so again in our
system it would be this back in the day
it could be gold coins or silver coins
now in that context then what do we mean
by fractional reserve banking it's
easier for say 100% reserve banking is
saying if the commercial banks have
issued claims legally binding claims
saying the owners of these things we are
promising on demand we will give you the
underlying base money if they have those
things a hundred percent stored in
reserve so for all the claims in the
community that the commercial banks have
issued if they have the base money 100
percent backing it up then that of
course is a hundred percent reserve
banking in contrast fractional reserve
banking means that the banks have issued
more claims to money saying anybody who
has this thing we promise you show up on
demand we will give you money and yet
they don't have a hundred percent of
those in the vault they've issued more
claims than they could actually back up
if everyone happened to show up at the
same time and this of course is what
makes bank runs possible so make sure
you understand under 100% reserve
banking bank runs don't happen whereas
it's fractional reserve banking by its
very nature this is no matter how wise
the banks investments have been that if
the customers all show up at once and
want to empty out their checking
accounts the banks helpless again it's
not a matter of the bank you know made
bad investments it's just that's the
nature of fraction reserve banking this
is the famous scene you might remember
the beginning of It's a Wonderful Life
right Jimmy Stewart's behind the counter
there's a panic in the community people
show up and they want their money and
what does Jimmy Stewart have to tell him
he doesn't have it well I'm sorry I gave
her money to Mary no I don't have it
right in case you're curious yes the
whole point of that was to do my
impression so
so--that's but again that is their it's
because that's the nature of fractional
reserve banking right that's what makes
bank runs possible so keep that in mind
now another distinction we should make
is between fiat money versus commodity
money so fiat money is you know tickets
issued by typically we're talking about
course of government's it's not backed
up by anything and the money is only
good to be money in contrast there's
what's called commodity money like gold
or silver coins for example where the
gold and silver are also regular
commodities but they also do double duty
as a money in the economy and so those
things that distinction between fiat and
commodity is not the same thing is
between 100 percent reserve in
fractional reserve and so there's four
logical possibilities I think it might
clarify the debate tonight if I just
walk through them really fast so you
could have commodity money like gold or
silver coins is the actual money in this
community and the banks also have to
keep 100% reserves so that kind of a
system was the one that Murray Rothbard
for example favored we could also
imagine having our current system for
example where there's fiat money and the
banks are allowed to issue more claims
on the fiat money than they have in the
vault
so there's fractional reserve banking
that's our current system a lot of
economists think that's fine like Paul
Krugman for example right and then we
have you can imagine when I think about
that
so and then we can also imagine that you
could have commodity money like gold or
silver coins is the actual money and yet
the banks have to and the banks though
are allowed to issue more claims on gold
and silver than they have in the vault
to back up so there's fractional reserve
banking but commodity money so make sure
you realize that's logically possible
and in fact that's the system that like
George sells you didn't Larry white talk
about in their writings on this topic
and then finally it's also logically
possible that you could have a system
that's got fiat money like you know
dollar bills but yet the big commercial
banks have to maintain 100% reserves or
in practice they do maintain 100%
reserves on that and actually believe it
or not some economists are in favor of
that
so at Prescott recently I think was in
2016 for example had a paper so he's
fine with having the dollar he doesn't
think the gold standard is a good idea
but he's fine with the dollar but he
thinks commercial banks should keep wish
you 100% reserves or should be held to
that standard and why does he think
that's as significant for tonight's
debate because he's saying that it's it
promotes stability a lot of economists
in the wake of the Great Recession the
financial crisis we're trying to say how
can we promote stability and one thing
that Prescott and other serious
award-winning mainstream economists have
been looking at is maybe we should stop
letting banks do this thing where they
issue more claims on money than they can
possibly fulfill in case there's a
crisis okay so the last sort of thing I
want to just mention is a hundred
percent reserve banking is possible all
right a lot of people when when this
topic comes up they scratch their even
economists I've I've gotten this
reaction they hear that somebody like
Murray Rothbard is against fractional
reserve banking and so they say well how
could that even work I mean how does a
bank is supposed to make money if it's
not allowed to take your to you know pay
you a low interest rate for your
checking account deposit and lend it out
to someone else at a higher rate and
earn the spread if you don't let banks
do that well then they would go out of
business why would there be banks okay
so that's not correct that that that
objection so what banks do there's
actually two distinct functions that
banks serve one is to be like a
storehouse or a warehouse for your money
just in terms of convenience and safety
right so that it's it's just more
convenient for you instead of carrying
around your cash on your person or in
your vault at your house the bank has
nice big vaults they have security
guards they have ATM machines all over
the world they've issued debit cards and
they have you know deals with networks
and so forth with restaurants and things
it's just much more convenient for you
whatever the base money is to be able to
store these things called banks and then
to be able to suspend it much more
easily around the world and there it's
safer to they you have to worry about a
burglar taking all of your money and so
that would be 100% reserves would apply
to and that's fine and the banks would
of course not be able to pay you
interest on your checking account they
would have to charge you somehow like me
to be a slight fee every time you wrote
a check or swipe your debit card there
might be a tiny little fee just for them
you know they're giving you a valuable
service in a market economy if people
want a service they pay for it and
that's that that's fine the other
distinct function that banks serve is to
be a credit intermediary
okay so you've got people over here who
want to save maybe you got like a
thousand people who want to save $200
each and then you got people over here
who want to borrow maybe somebody wants
to buy a house and they need a $200,000
mortgage in practice it would be hard
for them all to negotiate a bunch of
different deals for that and so the bank
stands in between them the savers deal
with the bank they lend their funds to
the bank and then the bank lends it out
and the bank has experts who can
evaluate creditworthiness and so forth
the bank's much better at evaluating
credit risks and so that that's the
service the bank is providing and it
earns a spread there the crucial thing
though is in that kind of scenario that
these savers are genuinely giving up
access to their money for the period of
the loan so for example if you buy a CD
a certificate of deposit from a bank
maybe the deal says okay you you buy it
for $100 today and then 12 months later
they give you one hundred and three
dollars back so during that year you're
not walking around thinking you've got
your hundred dollars in the bank and you
can go spend it at the grocery store if
you want to all right you you've lent it
to the bank it's not yours until they
pay you back with interest
so that kind of thing that happens
that's perfectly consistent with someone
who wants to have a hundred percent
reserve banking it's just checking
accounts that were called demand
deposits would be conceptually distinct
from you could call them time deposits
or savings accounts but the loans would
be different from putting your money on
deposit just for you to have them store
it for you all right so that's fine so
banking still works 100% reserves now
let me talk about what what's what's the
problem here okay so now we've set the
table here so what is the problem why is
fractional reserve banking inherently
destabilizing let me just go do a
historical thing cuz I think this is the
the best way to start out and think it
through and to see the essence of it and
why it's inherently dubious and it
distorts market economies and then as I
say after George prefers you know what
we'll get into the details of his world
view
so imagine historically the Goldsmith
right back in the day this is loosely
based obviously I'm cutting corners here
but this is roughly consistent with what
happened back in the day the Goldsmith's
you know they're making jewelry they're
making candlesticks they had a lot of
gold on them they had
vaults and so forth so the people in the
community realized you know what instead
of us storing our gold in our houses
we'll give it to them and they'll keep
it for us it's safer so they would do
that maybe pay him a little fee and so
the Goldsmith has issued tickets to the
people in the community so let's just
say they've given him a thousand ounces
of gold that's in his vault and there's
a thousand tickets now in the community
saying if I present this to mr. Smith
the goldsmith this gives me one ounce of
gold now it would think about it it
would be very cumbersome in practice if
somebody had to buy two hundred ounces
worth of goods for them to go of this
Smith give him two two hundred tickets
he gives them bags of a full two hundred
ounces of gold that person makes the
purchase then the seller walks over
gives them the gold coins and gets the
two hundred tickets back the buyer and
seller if they both trust Smith realize
that silly I'll just give you these
tickets and then we don't have to walk
back and forth and get the gold and put
it back in and so it's a sufficient
right it cuts down on the transaction
time and so once the community starts
doing that then Smith has an idea he
realizes the community as they come to
trust his tickets they don't feel the
need to come in and redeem them very
much and so just as long as anytime
someone shows up with those tickets that
he's issued he pays them off then the
community trusts it and they start
treating those tickets as if they're as
good as gold
they start functioning equivalently in
terms of economically and so then Smith
realized I got a thousand ounces of gold
in the vault and on any given day at
worst maybe thirty of them get taken out
I got 970 sitting there and then it gets
replenished and it bounces around but it
never goes below 920 let's say and he
realizes that's kind of wasteful she's
sitting there doing nothing now what he
could do is just be reckless and go buy
500 gold ounce was worth of stuff and
splurge but then he would permanently be
low in a case people wanted to redeem
the tickets he'd be be out of luck so
what he does is more clever is he
instead creates let's say 200 more
tickets and lends them out to a very
credit worthy businessperson who has a
project that's going to cost 200 ounces
of gold and he charges let's say 20
sorry 10 percent interest so that person
goes out does the project now there's
going to be more ticket claims than than
usual
he once he does that but still maybe
it'll go down to 700 that are sitting in
his vault or what have you
800 but he's still fine he's not nowhere
near being the position of not being
able to redeem a ticket if someone
presents it but notice the beauty of
that technique as long as that person
pays off the loan the next year what
happens the person pays 220 tickets back
right the 200 loan plus 20 and so then
Smith what does he do he the 200 that he
kind of created out of thin air he just
rips them up and then the 20 left that
were the interest on that loan those now
point to coins in his vault that are his
free and clear so he can take those 20
and do whatever he wants with it because
now the community only has 980 tickets
outstanding because 20 of them got paid
to him as an interest payment now there
was nothing coercive about the the
interest and so forth right that
merchant who borrowed the 200 he did
something voluntary that the community
valued and so that's how that person got
the 200 back plus the 20 extra now
what's the the problem is of course
Smith likes that deal right he he
effectively by just writing tickets out
of thin air lending them out and then
getting pay as long as he didn't make a
stupid loan and got paid back then he
gets access to some of the coins that
were in his wallet the community had put
there just because they didn't want to
be carrying them around and so that what
happened he you know he had to first
build up the trust but once he had done
that he's now able to earn interest off
of tickets that he floats over and above
coins that he can back up at any time so
as long as he never gets caught with
everybody panicking and turning all the
tickets in he can keep doing that so why
is this a problem well it goes back to
the Austrian theory of the business
cycle so here my time is limited so I'm
gonna have to hopefully assume most of
you are vaguely familiar with the
Austrian theory that Mises and Hayek
developed but that theory just to be
clear does not blame the boom-bust
unlike central banking know what that is
the theory is based upon is the
commercial banks ability to create money
and expand credit and the crucial thing
is think about the goldsmith he didn't
create those 200 tickets and just
distribute him randomly around the
community so they just pushed up prices
here and there what he specifically did
the way that 200 extra ounces entered
the economy was through the loan market
he lends it into the economy
and then when he absorbed the 200 and
destroyed it it was pulling it back
through the loan market from a loan
being paid off
so the first price that got distorted by
that new money and then pulling it out
was the interest rate the artificially
low interest rate stimulates a boom
which inevitably leads to a bust as
Mises and Hayek say and that's why
fractional reserve banking is inherently
destabilizing Georg for the negative
Georg salesmen please take the podium
take it away
Thank You Jean well you know after that
opening comedy act I have a feeling that
no matter how well I do at this debate
the Cato Institute is just not going to
be promoting that I do want to complain
to start with have a complaint for Jean
originally I thought I would have to say
nice things about bankers for 12 minutes
and that's pretty hard to do and now he
tells me I have to come up with 15
minutes of nice things to say about
bankers and I hope you'll agree that
makes my challenge much harder than
Bob's saying bad things for 15 minutes
but I'm gonna do my best of course what
I specifically have to say the nice
thing I have to say is that fractional
reserve banking does not pose a threat
to market economies in fact I'm gonna
argue that it's a very desirable market
institution that's been made a scapegoat
for other genuine threats now there are
actually two kinds of threats
fractional reserve banking is supposed
to pose and Bob has alluded to both of
them it's accused of causing systemic
banking crises as a result of bank runs
it's also accused of fueling
unsustainable booms not based on
people's voluntary savings I've got two
about 12 minutes I think their team to
counter both of those claims so let's
start with banking crises this is the
more popular concern of proponents of a
hundred percent reserves meaning
proponents who favor a Fiat hundred
percent reserve system Chicago plan of
the 1930s the sovereign money initiative
of the Swiss in recent years the
argument here goes as follows fractional
reserve
banks use deposits that can be cashed
out by their claimants at anytime they
used them to finance loans with definite
terms and this mismatching of maturities
with liabilities and assets makes the
banks vulnerable inherently vulnerable
to runs which are occasions again when
everybody wants their money out at once
and the banks of course can't possibly
come up with it if they're only holding
fractional reserves now I think even Bob
would agree that as far as this
arguments concerned isolated runs and
bank failures are tolerable and I would
say they're actually Sal salutary what
badly managed banks lose better one's
game because isolated runs people take
their money out of certain banks but
another some creditors may take losses
but you haven't got a systemic crisis
the problem is that bank runs are
supposedly contagious panic spreads from
bank to bank indiscriminately and there
can be widespread bank failures
resulting in a monetary contraction and
then a recession or even a depression so
what's wrong with this argument what's
wrong with it is it's more myth than
reality in fact there's surprisingly
little empirical foundation for this
scenario of banking crises the
proponents of the scenario almost always
involve give gave you a good example
they mention the run in It's a Wonderful
Life
the folks that's a movie now and not
only that it's a bad example because the
the the the Biddle
Savings and Loan are building and Loan
Bailey sorry Bailey's building and Loan
actually that run is started when Uncle
Bill loses eight thousand bucks so that
bank is actually very badly managed it
probably deserves to fail no matter how
much Jimmy Stewart pleads for it because
eight thousand bucks was real money in
1945 anyway this run is not random its
its depositors saying we hear that you
guys have blown it and we want to cash
out but a better example for the theory
would be the bank run in Mary Poppins I
don't know why this isn't
more often as evidence for the
proponents because there it's a pure
rumor right the kid wants his tuppence
and it it's actually nothing wrong with
the fidelity fiduciary bank it's
perfectly sound and yet there's a run
that shuts it down well here's the thing
real life bank runs are seldom
unprovoked they're almost always runs
that are in trouble on banks that are in
trouble before hand that have been badly
managed that their loans are not
performing etc take the runs of the
1930s which are usually cited as kind of
paradigm attic examples of unprovoked
bank runs the vast majority of those
runs were in response to genuine bad
news often concerning rural banks in
agricultural areas agriculture prices
were falling throughout the 1920s and
early 30s these banks were pre run
insolvent is the technical term they're
not being they're not failing because
they're being run upon they're run upon
because they're failing and the runs had
the desirable effect of shutting the
banks down quickly before they become
can pile up losses and it caused even
greater harm to their creditors in the
1930s also to pick that standard case
bank run contagions panics spreading
from bank to bank were rare and quite
limited what appeared to be bank
contagions started with the bank holiday
declared by the governor of Nevada
well holidays are contagious if you see
a governor sunny shutting down all the
banks in his state people in the next
state are gonna wonder whether that
governor is gonna do that too and that
was what started some apparent contagion
effects finally in 1933 as most people
in here know there was a big run in
February 33 continued until the National
bank holiday declared by Roosevelt that
was a run on the dollar sparked by
rumors that FDR would devalue no
monetary system that's on a gold
standard can stand such rumors but it
wasn't the banks that were distrusted it
was the government's fidelity to the
gold standard that was in question now
if we look outside the US
we see even more evidence against the
notion that fractional reserve banking
is inherently vulnerable to crises take
Canada up north 1930s how many banks
failed in Canada zero Canada was hit
harder by the depression than the US was
in most respects but had a sound banking
system and because of that it had no
bank failures there's no evidence of
inherent vulnerability what's the
difference between the US and Canada
simple we had lousy Bank regulations in
those days we had new lousy regulations
now in those days we had unit banking no
bank could have branches were very few
so they were under diversified tiny
under capitalized Canadian banks branch
nationwide and we're big and had lots of
capital they could withstand big shocks
and they were diversified so the theory
if you would look at other countries
saying you get more evidence that
there's plenty of sound banking systems
out there fractional reserve they've
never been any hundred percent reserve
banking systems by the way that's
something you should wonder about
there's never been a law against it
right like some of the laws some people
would like to have against fractional
reserves in any event but the theory
doesn't fit inherent vulnerability
doesn't fit there's an alternative
theory that the US example points to but
if you look at world evidence as I have
you can see that it all fits banking
crises are due to dumb banking
regulations bad government regulations
now I don't have time to elaborate but I
oppose you this challenge I used to do
it to my students you show me a bank in
crisis I'll show you bad regulations not
just fractional reserves takes more than
that to cause a crisis so what's
happened here what's happening here is
fractional reserve banking is being made
a scapegoat for wrongheaded banking
regulations it's being blamed for what's
not an inherent problem to it where
regulations bad government regulations
are the true cause and I can show you by
for any evidence you name now let's talk
about business cycles the charge here is
that fractional reserve banks
keenly engage in lending that's not
financed by corresponding acts of Satan
causing unsustainable malinvestment
booms that's the Austrian theory now
first of all I want to say that I'm not
opposed to this theory and I agree that
lending not backed by voluntary savings
contributes to business cycles however I
deny that fractional reserve banks
routinely engaged in such lending now
competitive banks in fact and we're
talking about competitive commercial
banks here not central banks those are
an exception our seldom a source of
lending in excess of voluntary savings I
hope most of you will agree if not all
of you then when people place funds with
banks for definite terms and they know
Bob agrees because he just practically
made this argument say they buy a
certificate of deposit or savings
account where there's a term to the
deposit that those people are engaged in
voluntary savings making it okay for
their banks and for the banking system
to engage in the same amount of lending
okay so what about demand deposits the
difference here is not one in kind but
one of degree funds placed in a demand
deposit account and by the way this was
true in the days of the Goldsmith's and
even in the earliest beginnings of
banking and I can go into the law on
this if we bring it up in question time
funds placing a demand deposit also
still represent voluntary savings only
these savings have no specific term they
are so many call loans or demand loans a
perfectly common thing in finance or
have loans that are made with no
specific term you can ask for the money
back an overdraft account as a car loan
securities markets banks make car loans
to them all the time now banks aren't
earning not lending on the basis of no
voluntary savings they're lending on the
basis of voluntary savings where they
have to estimate to what extent for how
long the savings are at their disposal
notice this poses an extra challenge of
course bankers have to guess how many
savings are at the disposal and for how
long
many depositors helps of course because
although some are taking money out the
large numbers can usually result in
offsetting deposits
so the actual pool of savings that are
available voluntary savings is more
constant than the actions of individual
pot depositors might suggest still of
course it's true that bankers don't
always guess right there's risk but
that's why we have fractional reserve
banks rather than zero reserve banks the
reserves are there to provide a margin
of error reasonably safe reserve ratios
are determined by bankers through the
experience just like capital ratios they
learn what cushion they can get away
with and over time that cushion changes
according to experience in any event
when a competitive bank overestimates
the voluntary savings at its disposal
that Bank discovers the error very
quickly the reserve real losses there's
not much scope
therefore for systematic over-expansion
lending beyond savings individual bank
lends more than its customers are
willing to provide it runs out of
reserves so systematic over lending in
the competitive system is very rare so
why do we have boom bust cycles well we
have them mostly because of central
banks central bank's IOUs
even under a gold standard tend to be
used as reserves by other banks so those
central banks aren't subject to the same
discipline of competitive banks where
their notes and checks are being
returned actively so when a central bank
expands instead it's like a Pied Piper
for the whole system the other banks
have more reserves so they expand as
well but what has to drive this as a
central bank so here again you have a
case by the way I have a whole paper
about it called bank lending manias in
theory in history we look at the most
famous lending booms and show that in
every case it's not the reserve ratio
falling it's money being created by
central bank driving the whole system to
expand with a fixed reserve ratio and
this is another case where fractional
reserve banking has been made a
scapegoat
real culprit has been central bank
misconduct do you want to solve the
problem don't throw up the fractional
reserve baby get rid of the central bank
bathwater the quick sides while
fractional reserve banks aren't to blame
for malinvestment they play a crucial
role in avoiding under investment which
happens if let when lending falls short
of voluntary savings asked me during the
question period and I'll elaborate now I
want to add a couple points in the last
minute or so on the positive role
fractional reserve banks play that 100
percent reserve banks couldn't possibly
play and by the way if you think those
fees would be puny in the system that
Bob was talking about where you still
use debit cards etc but you don't have
the bank isn't using your money you can
forget about it you think your fees are
lousy now wait till you see how much
that cost that may have something to do
with the fact that this alternative Bob
brings up has never been popular
historically even though it's always
been legal even in the days before
deposit insurance
nobody wanted to that deal banks could
have offered it what happened to the
market if it's so good why didn't any
banker ever think of offering this
alternative system and advertising that
the other banks were cheating anyway
banks and economic development I don't
want to come across as a fractional
reserve Pollyanna even the best
regulated fractional reserve system
won't be trouble-free some banks will
fail some creditors will occasionally
lose money banks will take part in booms
all these things are course less likely
that with a hundred percent reserves but
fractional reserve banking has one huge
benefit that more than compensates for
its cost which is the efficient
employment of the public scarce savings
I can't elaborate on this either in the
time I have left 30 seconds I refer you
to book 2 chapter 2 of The Wealth of
Nations for an eloquent discussion by
Adam Smith of how Scotland in the course
of a hundred years from 1700 1800 went
from being a poor country to being
almost as rich in per capita terms as
England all thanks or largely thanks and
according to Smith and many others to
its efficient free fractions our banking
system so parting analogy if you don't
mind it's easy to fix one for all
if you ignore others but this is one of
those cases where the fix is worse than
the problem thank you very much
[Applause]
repot oil from Bob Murphy okay well one
of George's points is easy to respond to
he wondered why didn't bring up Mary
Poppins because my impression of her is
terrible
so that's obvious all right now he asked
now he mentioned some things that he
said words the effect of Everett Lake
looking for every crisis and by the way
notice he start out by listing all the
various economists who have proposed
methods of limiting fractional reserve
banking so this this isn't some crank
idea that just Murray Rothbard and his
followers are into there are plenty of
mainstream with Chicago school guys and
so forth who have dabbled with this
because they they're noticing that
there's inherent instability and there
of course grappling with ways of trying
to contain it but he said for every me
no major problem they point to when
apparently fractional reserve banking
led to this huge disaster he can find
other government regulations that were
also there that contributed to it well I
agree with that the only way we would
know is if there were like in you know
in the ancap world somewhere society
that the only things they allowed
fractional reserve banking him that
would be the test case and then we could
see once and for all whether it works
now but in the historical record of
course we're never going to see that
exact experimental case and of course I
agree that you know the laws were unit
banking FDR you're threatening to
devalue and then following through with
it all those things of course those are
destabilizing and that will make it
worse so yes looking back through
history the worst crises like the
benchmark we used to say wow that was
really an unstable economy for that
period wasn't it the worst stuff that
government all did put together is going
to produce the worst results so of
course looking back at what we think of
as really bad messed up economies we're
gonna say yeah there was more than just
fractures or a banking going on but just
think through what I said I mean that's
obvious whatever the truth is of
fractures our banking what I just said
is gonna be the way history looks okay
and so what we're debating though
tonight is to say suppose we put those
things aside is fracture reserve banking
inherently unstable so let me just
before I refer back to his specific
points they just make my argument here
again he agreed with the Austrian theory
of the business cycle the essence of it
right and so those who are familiar with
it so again I'm going to repeat my claim
that George didn't challenge the last
one that the Austrian business cycle
theory was not developed to explain how
central bank's caused the boom-bust
cycle it was explaining how the
commercial banks expand credit through
the loan market and that the if you're
familiar with the term Cantillon effects
that when new monetary inflation enters
the economy it doesn't just cause a
general price rise it hits specific
sectors first and distorts relative
prices and so the Austrian business
cycle theory is just a particular
application of that saying if the way
the new money enters the economy is not
from a helicopter drop but through the
commercial banking system the first
prices that it screws up are the
interest rates and it lower interest
rates give a false signal to
entrepreneurs to start long-term
projects that's why fractional reserve
banking per se is inherently unstable so
yes if that were the only thing and
government didn't do anything else to
screw up the economy I agree that would
be less unstable than what we see in the
real world when government does all that
put together but still the essence of
tonight what we're saying is fraction
reserve banking per se is inherently
unstable and so far George I think has
has not challenged my claim that that's
what Austrian business cycle theory is
about now as far as I think the main
thing that his alluding to it the
remainder of my time here let me just
focus it's a critical element in
George's case here and by the way his
argument is is is very elegant so if you
haven't read the literature on this and
since seen his argument very clever and
it's a it's a beautiful idea I just
think it happens to be wrong okay and
what I want to say is he's saying oh no
the one special case when fractional
reserve banking doesn't cause the
boom-bust cycle is if the community
wants to hold more of these deposits
under his free banking system the
commercial banks only in create more
money if you will and lend it out when
the community wants to hold more and so
he's saying that is genuine savings okay
and well I want to just challenge it and
say no it's not so there's two ways one
is just the real quick glib way when he
was saying look it's a
spectrum it's a matter of degree you can
have a one-year loan a six-month loan
and basically when you put money in a
checking account that's like a very
short-term loan you just keep rolling
over no that that's not the same thing
look I could say man I had a bad job I
went to the gym yesterday I was on there
for 45 minutes and then later so you
know what well next week you see me in a
sink
I was really bad last night I went to
the gym I didn't stay very long at all
they said how long do you say Oh zero
minutes that's equivalent to saying I
didn't go to the gym okay it's not that
I went to the gym for a very short time
once it's zero that's it when you give
money into a checking account and it's
your money he even said I remember he
said those few you think the fees would
be puny if the bank's not allowed to use
your money that's the look at that was
the words he said right that when you
have money in a checking account you're
walking around thinking you can spend
that you're not relinquishing control
that's the whole point of these whether
called money substitutes right the
commercial banks have issued claims on
money that's circulate in the community
they're as good as money and so that's
why it's inherently destabilizing
because it's not really you're not
lending money to the bank thank you
George George your final rebuttal bob
keeps mentioning all the economists who
favor a hundred percent reserves and
there are a fair number there are a lot
more who don't favor a hundred percent
reserves let's not forget that the vast
majority and I've looked at all of these
he cooked these arguments from the
various schools not just the Austrian
schools and one thing they all have in
common was that remarkable lack of
historical evidence and awareness I'm
afraid in most cases they just don't
look at very many countries and they
look at the u.s. badly that is they
don't really study carefully what
actually happened even here we do have
plenty of evidence look there are no
pristine unregulated banking systems but
we can see patterns in different
countries at different times of where
the crises happen what kinds of
regulations they have and I've done a
study of this a couple studies actually
and it's overwhelmingly clear
that the least regulated banking systems
of the past including ones without
central banks particularly performed
very well and forests of the frequency
of crises the u.s. just happens to be a
particularly bad case it leads the race
of those countries that have been
studied in frequency of crises and in
bad back banking regulations gone all
the way back now Bob mentioned the can't
alone effects well if you want to blame
something for Cantillon effects you
should start with gold since that's was
a case study that Cantillon actually
originally emphasized there was a
discovery of gold and how it pours into
the monetary system and effects relative
prices and so on I'm not making an
argument against gold I'm just saying
that Cantillon himself didn't
particularly single out fractional
reserve banks I would like to say
something in this matter of degree
versus it's a difference in kind a call
loan is a call loan for as long as it
lasts collectively all of us leave money
in our deposits sometimes for a long
time not sometimes for not very long
with the pooling of large numbers of
such deposits and the constant inflow
and outflow bankers can reasonably
assume they have a certain amount that's
available to them for a fairly long time
and can make loans and do this routinely
as for it being in any way contrary to
the rights of contractual agreements
there's no truth to that at all even in
the days of the Goldsmith's and I can
refer you to an article I've written
called those dishonest Goldsmith's
publishing in the financial history
review all about the origins of
fractional reserve banking could not I
could not find any trace of evidence of
there being anything dishonest look
there's an old legal rule that goes back
to ancient times it's older than
Goldsmith banking which gets started in
this is 17th century and it goes back to
Judaic law and for all I know it's older
than that I've called it the bagging
rule it's a very simple principle if you
brought money to a money changer and
later to a goldsmith and it was in a
sealed container
the understanding was that the coins in
the sealed container were still your
property and you were putting it there
for storage if you brought loose coins
the presumption was that you were making
they became the property of the banker
there were good reasons legally for this
having to do with the lack of earmarking
of coins but the old from ancient times
was understood the coins
the ownership went with possession
unlike with most goods and this was a
very very old legal doctrine and by the
time of the Goldsmith's everyone
understood if you didn't put it in a bag
and you didn't say otherwise you're
making a loan to the banker you're not
making a bailment deposit in the strict
sense the money belongs to the banker
what you own is a claim that gives you
the right to have it back when you asked
for it and by the way that's the only
reasonable legal claim you could have
because otherwise strictly speaking with
a bailment this banker would have to
surrender the particular coins and
that's where I they would have to be in
a sealed container this was all
long-established law by the time the old
first fractional reserve banks got
started fraud had nothing to do with it
nothing it's a complete myth that
belongs in bad undergraduate textbooks
so so and we should stop repeating it
because there's not an ounce of truth to
it
that's really all I have to say about
about those points we have the history
we have the reality of the law and we
have the theory that doesn't say that
any fractional reserve bank lending is
going to cause a business cycle it says
only that lending that's not based on
savings which a competitive bank can
hardly get away with is going to
contribute to business cycles that's why
empirically central banks turn out to be
the true culprits
[Applause]
thank you guys due to extremely worthy
opponents as I'm sure you both agree
vigorous vigorous people debating each
other this evening you want to line up
at the mic over there to give us your
questions first I want to ask either
side George do you want to put a
question to Bob now Bob do you want a
question put a question to George would
you want to wait for the audience
huh guys but I'd waive it I would maybe
wait in case the audience doesn't asks
the really zingers okay George you want
but George you have a right yeah he's
pick up the mic he wanted to sing God
you have that mic why are you letting up
I want a lob a couple of questions that
at both of you George you you conceded
that as far as the argument goes in a
way 100 percent backing is a little bit
more stable but then you had a bad only
a very short time to say ah but there's
something else and and as far as I
gathered you seem to say well it's
cheaper it's more efficient but could
you elaborate on what you mean but what
is the advantage affections that
minimizes instability could you write so
fraction fractional reserve banking does
have costs it does mean in Adam Smith
recognizes - it does mean that banks
will be more vulnerable to failure right
and people will occasionally even
creditors will lose money if the if the
capital isn't there although when we
didn't have Deposit Insurance with 25
percent capital ratios for banks as a
protection against that but bad things
will happen but it's the the counterpart
the reason why it's worth it miss Smith
argued and many others since is that
you're taking a large sum of savings
that are actually there that our little
driblets here there and everywhere and
you're accumulating them and investing
them productively that's what the
Scottish banks did that's what
fractional reserve banks generally do
sometimes well sometimes not so well and
that adds up to a lot more economic
growth and development and
that of course is a very important Rondo
Cameron an economic historian late
economic historian from university of
from emory wrote two books all about
this banking and there in the and
industrialization and banking and
economic development he and his
co-authors surveyed all the history of
all the industrialized nations in one
book and then the history of many unand
us realized ones and the other asking
what banking did or didn't do in the
answer that came out of this was the
freest banking systems contributed to
industrialization in countries that
suppressed their banks which meant in
practice fractional reserve banks did
not industrialize banking played a
crucial role although the wealth were
used to today banking fractional reserve
banking because there has never been any
other kind with rare exceptions all
state-sponsored by the way is what made
it possible for the industrialized
countries to get that way that's no
small thing i do you want to comment on
george's answer well sure if he just
parse what he just said he said okay the
you know the historian they look and see
that those country the governments that
didn't mess with the banks and just let
him do what they wanted to they would
they grew whereas the ones that
regulated worked and then he added in a
second by the way there's never been
100% reserve banking so that proves that
these governments that were intervening
in their banking sector it wasn't to
enforce 100 percent reserves so yeah i
have no problem with the argument or the
claim historically if you look at states
that interfere with their banks they
tend to grow less than states that you
know i'm not for regulating by the way i
am not for the government even if
somebody releases chemical gas i don't
want the government punishing that I'm
certainly not gonna say punish them for
issuing fraction reserve banking so this
is not an argument about political
crackdowns on banks we're talking about
the economic so that's what I'm doing
tonight my question you Bob is in terms
of this idea about the demand deposits
and savings if if there is complete
transparency which I think you still if
indeed everybody says all banks say
you're depositing this money and we have
a great presentation from Bob Murphy
from the Seoul forum and exactly what
this means with that there's going to be
fraction reserve banking this is what it
means
there's
the risks you value sign document you
understand the risk what do you choose
and then let's say everybody choose
factions are bragging cuz it's cheaper
the cheaper alternative so what would
you say that that's sort of like an
affirmative action to say well okay I'm
saving
I'll leave it's like a coal loan would
you would you concede that argument or
what would be your pushback about that
okay so let me clarify George set up
there he said winners were the last
remarks
let's stop repeating the claim that this
is fraud I didn't say it was fraud okay
so I guess other people who have my side
on this they do make that argument I'm
not saying it's fraud alright what I'm
saying is economically so yes I'm saying
economically when you have money in a
checking account
you don't view that is that you're
lending money to the bank you still
think you can spend that money it's
serving the same function to you as if
you kept cash in your purse or your
wallet and that's why the merchants in
the community I mean that's why we're
not worried about bonds right because
you can't go to the store and buy
something with bonds typically but you
can spend them with claims on money
issued by banks that's the whole reason
Mises developed his theory of what he
called money substitutes and so forth
was that claims on banks that are
considered perfectly legitimate and no
doubt then the community treats them is
equivalent to money so that's the
problem what if everybody listened to
Scylla forum debate Celgene concedes
there are risks involved you tell people
look this money may not be there you
know whatever you want to say so they
say well I want to do it anyway so
there's no complete transparency when
would you say that that then they're
saving the money in a sense when they
say well I understand the risk I would
rather just have the fraction rather
than on to present because the fraction
is cheaper well what would you would you
agree that that's that would be savings
if there's complete transparency and
then the monies that may not be there no
okay so the the problem is so no I don't
think so because there's - there's now
two sets of people walking around having
access to the same savings and so that
that economically that they can't you're
you're having the benefits of command
over present goods you could spend it if
you wanted to and yet you've effectively
lent the money out so no I don't think
it's the same thing I said
first question please phrase your
creditors your question as a question
and tell us who you might be addressing
it to if anybody thank you thank you
both for coming out tonight intimating
actually you guys answered my question
in the last minute or so so stove more
lighthearted question for dr. Murphy in
your book choice you mentioned different
groups or different people minting gold
coins and one of them was actually the
Celgene mint is that referring to you're
debating a point opponent tonight yeah
okay no I do think that Celgene is mint
but yeah that was an homage I saw him
give a talk at the Mises Institute on
the the history of private coinage so
yes that the the mark the market can
produce money it can produce banking
services that you don't need the
government to be involved in money in
banking at all so yes that was an homage
to the talk I saw him give about how
beautiful the coins were that private
mints produced okay let's not give nice
guys let's sell it next question please
questions for both is there a
qualitative difference between
fractional reserve banking and say
someone like myself counterfeiting money
and then lending it yes there is because
there's no there's no illegal activity
involved in fractional reserve banking
the bank is make is taking in credit in
the form of car loans that are made to
it it's an intermediary as we say and it
is turning around and on behalf of the
people lending to it it is making loans
to others and as soon as the lending to
it ceases that is the end of the
availability of credit to the bank and
as to curtail its own loans accordingly
and this is exactly what goes on in
competitive banking systems they lend as
much as they can lend because the money
is at their disposal though no one has
made a specific agreement that's
regarding how long and then they have to
estimate that but they're not blending
anything that doesn't that's
illegitimate they're not creating claims
that are different in kind from the
kinds
of claims they create when they deal
with term deposits the only difference
is they have to speculate less with
terms deposits it's not as tricky but
large numbers of independent depositors
make it not so difficult to be a
fractional reserve bank or and be
prudent about it once you introduce
deposit insurance indeed then you start
having a lot less prudence because the
depositors themselves are less picky
about where they put their money that's
when things really go south coming
father
well well notice I mean George went
right to the legality of it and so that
I think that is a hint here that there
is that your question was clothed the
nature of what's happening there so I
yes I would say if you understood why
just you being able to print up
hundred-dollar bills but but it's not
it's not just the fact that that's
inflationary it's if you lent them out
that that's really the issue so be to be
clear I am NOT talking about the
fraudulent even though there are people
who make those claims with the bailment
contracts there is that literature
that's not what I'm here saying I'm
saying that if the money enters through
the loan market those prices get pushed
down first and those are not the correct
prices that the community has not saved
more just because the banks decide to
issue more tickets Oh
next question hi there this question is
more for Bob but I would love if both of
you guys wanted to weigh on this it
seems to me that the crux of this issue
it really boils down to the inflationary
does inflationary pressure inflationary
activity lead to a boom and then a bust
and that can be through a central bank
it can be through fractional reserve and
it seems like there's a bit of a debate
in that point whether a fractional
reserve does in fact inflate or not in
my opinion it seems clear it does and so
my question really is what is it about
the inflationary behavior that leads to
malinvestment the boom well the boom I
understand but then the eventual bust
why why does that inflation be fiat
fractional reserve or in central bank
whatever lead to malinvestment and then
and then a bust okay Bob check it but I
want you to respond to George okay so
yes I and I believe in you know George's
framer he call
inside money so I don't think he's gonna
deny that there's a sense in which banks
create money when he's gonna say under
his scenario it's not destabilizing so
from my perspective again if the problem
is you need to know what interest rates
do they if the community genuinely saves
and refrains from consumption that frees
up resources then if it goes through the
loan market lower interest rates tell
entrepreneurs oh there's more real
savings to invest in longer-term
projects so if the community hasn't
refrained from consumption and the
reason more loans are available is
because now the banks are issuing more
claims then that price is wrong that's
why if it enters through the so it's not
inflation per se that we're talking
about tonight it's that if inflation
comes through the loan market and just
the nature of fracture reserve banking
when banks create money in a certain
sense that's how the new money enters
the economy is through a loan I just
want to elaborate on the question of
fractional reserves and inflation it's
just not true that fractional reserve
banking involves a higher inflation rate
generally if you have a system with the
ten percent reserve just to speak of
that case and another with a hundred
percent reserve and let's say gold is
flowing into each system at the rate of
five percent per year and there's no
changes in overall than people's demand
for money and I suppose it's constant
the price the inflation rate will be an
output is constant the inflation rate
will be five percent in the 100 percent
reserve system and it will be five
percent in the ten percent reserve
system the reserve ratio doesn't tell
you about the rate of growth of the
money supply being any different once
you've settled into that reserve ratio
it's not great if you're growing a
reserve fractional reserve system out of
nothing then you have a one time
increase in the price level we have a
question that came in from the from the
virtual space inevitably we can't talk
about money and Becky with that quote
talking about Bitcoin and so one of the
questions of course that came in is
could Bitcoin or any other
cryptocurrency be some kind of base
money as gold once was could Bitcoin
become some kind of base money as gold
once was
somewhat relevant to the debate could
both of you respond to it well
Bitcoin if it where money would be based
money it's it's not a claim or an I or
you which is what inside money to use
the expression Bob use is so the Bitcoin
can't be anything but a base money if
it's money at all right whether it's
money it all depends on how widely used
it is is that medium exchange so then
the question that grows out of that is
can you have a fractional reserve
banking system develop on top of a
Bitcoin standard and the answer is in
principle you can whether the regulators
would ever allow such a thing of course
I doubt it very much
any comment well sure so yeah like
George said I mean in the Austrian
monetary framework bitcoins clearly a
medium of exchange but is it's not it's
not universally accepted so I would say
technically it's not money right now but
in principle if everybody embraced it
and used it then it could be a money at
that point the the narrow point just for
the the Chu purists in the room were
familiar this literally very quickly say
about that is all of the things that
George talks about the benefits of
having like a flexible or expansionary
currency that you have with fractional
reserve banking in principle if you had
a crypto currency that was tied to like
maintaining a certain you know price
level of a basket of commodities or
whatever you could theoretically imagine
that sort of framework and that new
money would not need to enter the
economy through the loan sector so I
think all the problems with you know
sticky prices and the alleged benefits
of FRB just as a counter example just
imagine a world where the crypto
currency comes in and just you know
regulates the price level so if there's
a deflationary shock or inflationary the
quantity of base money expands or
contracts and that doesn't have the
alleged problems of gold so I'm just
saying conceptually that's not I'm
favoring it but think through the logic
of that if you're really hip deep in
this literature to see his claims about
FRB actually don't work or you don't
need them because you can imagine that
logical fractional reserve banking there
are actually two separate issues here
one is whether the money supply is a
whole adjusts in a way that avoids
problems of
severe deflation that sort of thing and
and that is ultimately that's ultimately
a challenge of getting your base money
right you know you either have to rely
on a very competent and perhaps
omniscient central banker or you better
pick the right commodity or come up with
a clever cryptocurrency that that's
smart macroeconomic terms that's
different from the Adam Smith point
which is about being not squandering
resources on your money supply
unnecessarily so gold is very expensive
and as many of you know cryptocurrency
is also very expensive stuff it's a high
cost of production and the coins are
worth exactly the energy that goes into
them in the in equilibrium so it's
expensive what Smith is talking about is
the social savings I know that sounds
communist but that means the savings to
society alright don't get old
there's no issed there the that's a
savings to society of making a little
gold go a lot further in having a money
supply that's ten percent gold and and
and ninety percent credit versus a
hundred percent gold it's very expensive
to have a hundred percent money supply
and this is not inconsistent what
Smith's is favoring is totally
consistent with having a the the lending
that's going on behind a fractional
reserve system be a perfect mirror image
of people's willingness to hold IO use
instead of base money so you hold IO use
your willingness to do that for any
length of time supply savings to the
banks they can lend and in turn you get
a money supply that's a lot cheaper in
real resource costs and society can use
those savings to invest more and produce
more that's separate from the behavior
of the price level and all that okay
yeah so just to make sure you got what
he was saying Smith's argument was that
it would be wasteful to have to like dig
up all these gold coins what if instead
we could have just 10% the gold coins
and the 90% of the money being claims
golde then that 90% of the gold's not
sitting uselessly in vaults it's freed
up I'll return to that point in my in my
closing remarks but let me just mention
that you know that that is a distinct
point so that's one possible downside of
fractional reserve banking in terms
sorry 100% reserve banking is that
perhaps there's this fixed overhead and
what I would say it worse that's that's
analogous to saying well you know it's
really expensive that people have to put
locks on doors and if we could just free
up those resources but given the way the
reality is that putting those locks
that's that's optimal right now and we
can imagine a different world so I would
say you know that's that's what I'll say
here I'll come back to that point and
then the closing as well
next question thanks so much for the
debate given that I know this is more of
a macroeconomic expediency debate rather
than a fraud legal debate but given that
the most natural and intuitive
understanding of a banknote is under
100% fractional reserve banking
what is the contractual nature of a
banknote under fractional reserve
banking and also if you have a system
with fractional and 100 reserve banking
in a free market simultaneously aren't
those contracts different in nature and
also the same question about different
percentages of fractions in fractional
reserve a banknote is and always has
been an IOU it's a debt instrument I
have a little article I have a blog sort
of a blog so our essay on called
Ultimates from it's it's Cato so make
what you will of that but but but it's
it's called
bank notes never aren't and never have
been bailment instruments and it shows a
bunch of old bank notes commercial bank
notes and then it shows a bunch of
bailment certificates and you can see
the language is completely different
completely different a bailment
certificate always says we have on
deposits this stuff for you a bank note
says we will pay this note on demand for
X dollars so that's what they are that's
what bank notes evolved they've never
been tickets they've never been property
certificates as the
some of the literature from the Austrian
says all of that is just not true of
what banknotes ever have been so that's
their legal foundation they're an IOU
they're more like a little bearer bond
the circulating bearer bond with a call
option a put option by Department and
and and that's the legal foundation the
money that you surrendered when you took
the banknote or a deposit credit balance
became instantly the bankers property to
do whatever the banker wanted but the
banker had an obligation to come up with
a certain amount of money when you came
to ask for it which could be that very
day
and if the banker didn't meet that
obligation the banker was in default
with severe repercussions so that's the
legal foundation yeah I mean I'm not
sure so again I want to be clear I don't
want people to confuse this is that I am
NOT here arguing from legality or saying
there's fraud going on I'm speaking
economic let me just try this analogy
maybe this will help
imagine economists watching someone at a
restaurant the guy goes into the
restaurant he takes his coat off
he hands it over the counter he gets a
piece of paper he goes and eats his meal
for an hour comes back gives a piece of
paper and gets his coat back if we as
economists said huh he lent his coat to
the restaurant for one hour and then he
gave him two dollars so there must have
been a negative interest rate this is
interesting right we would be
misunderstanding what happened he wasn't
lending the restaurant his coat he was
just saying it would be inconvenient for
me to carry my coat around and have it
with me while I eat so I'll let them
hang on to it I still have all the
advantages of having instant access to
my coat if I want it likewise when you
make a deposit into your checking
account and the fat it's crucial to the
argument that those balances the claims
on the bank circulate in the community
effectively as money and so that's how
you're actually not giving up anything
you're not suffering the you know it all
why are you putting in a checking
account rather than buying a 12 month CD
because you're thinking I might want to
spend this tomorrow
and so it's serving economically the
same function as money in your wallet so
long as they don't default on it or you
know say you can't redeem it and so
that's why it's theirs
problem again that's the whole reason
Mises developed this distinction he had
money substitutes then what he called
fiduciary media and money certificates
that's why he developed it because he
said there's something peculiar here
when the community begins accepting
these claims to be basically as good as
money that that's that opens up
Pandora's box Jesus didn't didn't have
room in his classification for for
callable loans obviously because that's
what that's what the debate here is
about is the legitimacy of deposits that
are that are that that are basically
just call them alone without a term
anyway that's not what I wanted to say I
wanted to say something more about
banknotes because it's germane to the
question of a hundred percent versus
fractional banking until relatively
recent times banknotes circulating IOUs
where the more common form of bank
liability whereas deposits that were
checkable they were used by well-to-do
people for fairly large transactions but
the common people were more likely to
deal with a bank by holding its paper io
u--'s you cannot have circulating paper
IR used at least not with any technology
that has been had been extant in the
past with a hundred percent reserve
backing and that's because the ownership
in order if the ownership is changing
all the time that is the person holding
the note who owns the gold because now
we're talking about a certificate not an
IOU that person is changing anonymously
the bank can't send a bill to the person
whose gold is being stored and therefore
cannot charge for the service unless
some sucker wants to pay perpetually for
gold that he's passed their certificate
on to somewhere else so the whole idea
of circulating banknotes in a hundred
percent reserve system is a non-starter
it never would have worked you could
only have deposits where people could
transfer the deposit balances but there
could be no circulating notes next
question my questions for George if we
were to have a nurses standardization
rather
then a let's say a legality form of
banking would that not create more of a
natural cycle to put the proper amount
of capital in the system so like if you
have 100 percent reserve of what I
deposit in the bank then all my
transactions are like 6% whereas if I
have 20 percent that the banks allow to
loan out and then I'm allowed to do all
of my transactions through the bank at
0% with that not create more of a
natural sliding scale I mean I go to the
store and I buy shower curtains and
there's 12 and I buy a curtain and
there's 12 holes and I buy a rod and
they all fit together would that not
naturally happen in a situation like
that and create the proper ironic credit
could you explain the question as you
understand it George and I'm not sure I
fully understand that
I think thing what you want to respond
to well what part do you want I think
the question is why don't the bank's
just say look we have 10% reserve
accounts 50% reserve accounts and so on
and you pick it and it's all specified
like that right and in the the answer is
that the reason bank reserve ratios have
to be able to fluctuate for fractional
reserve banking to work well because
there are unpredictable changes the bank
bank cannot conveniently predict and
state a fixed reserve ratio without
putting itself in the position where it
can't use the reserves when it needs to
we have to we shouldn't be speculating
about what the martin and this is the
bigger answer your question why are we
speculating about what bankers might do
might offer to their customers when
we've had now three four centuries of
banks in many places offering different
products they've discovered they
discovered fractional reserves they
discovered how to administer them and
for the most part though we know all the
horror stories and in some places much
more obviously this system worked very
well for many many many people bad
banking systems have always existed I'm
afraid there are more of them now than
ever but we can trace that to the
pernicious interventions of
government adulterating what was Ottawa
otherwise be a very satisfactory market
product to pick up my question George
have you said I think you've gone
directly saying that Scotland actually
practice something like 5% backing in 18
in the 1820s already Scottish banks
generally kept specie reserves of more
like 1% 1 to 2% with second day reserves
in the form of Exchequer bills that
could be easily cashed in London and
this was a result of experience and they
had almost a century of very very stable
and productive banking and a Scotsman
who got hold of a gold Guinea couldn't
wait to trade it for a good Scottish
banknote they wanted nothing to do with
those clunky old coins do you do you
think that that what would happen we'd
have like 1% with them well I don't know
what would happen now but but the past
speaks very clearly on the potential for
a fractional reserve banks when they're
properly regulated and structured to get
by with very low reserves and yet be
incredibly safe and solid Canada is
another very good example of that again
about a from 1872 depending you run you
want to cut it off 1935 or World War one
very very stable banking system with
with more goat role for government than
Scotland but still relatively little
government intervention common popular I
just asked for a point I've heard claims
that the Scottish banks suspended specie
Redemption for like 23 years or
something do you agree with that or yes
they did what happened was something
called the Napoleonic Wars Wars do have
a way of disrupting things including all
kinds of things that normally would work
differently and what happened was in
1797 England went off the gold standard
and of course Scotland was basically as
very small the economy very heavily
involved in trade with England and it
just didn't make any sense for the
Scottish banks to
to retain the gold standard while the
rest of the British Isles went off so
they suspended in sympathy and probably
more or less illegally for the only time
but their customers did not mind and
were rather relieved actually believe it
or not all accounts suggested the
English people were very glad when the
the English bank suspended because they
were very fearful of what was going to
happen to the banking system otherwise
so yes this is you know an example
though of a force majeure which is
something that can upset insurance
contracts all kinds of normal market
arrangements get made topsy-turvy we
shouldn't expect any market institution
to be able to hold out under all
circumstances next question hi my
question is for dr. Murphy there seems
to be a tendency for both the debaters
to agree that there is a tendency
towards fractional reserve banking in a
free society so my question is in a
stateless society how would you enforce
a hundred percent reserves this is gonna
have to be the last question because
we're running out of time
object okay let me my position that I'm
taking for this debate is actually the
one that Mises takes in human act and I
think this will clarify so I'm I'm okay
with being for free banking I don't want
political interferes with the banks I
just think under genuine open
competition in markets property rights
and so forth that you know the private
courts would enforce banks would be lent
you know the same sort of mechanism and
considerations that George and Larry
White talked about and some of their
work I think we just hold them much
closer hun percent reserve much higher
than the one to three percent that he
said he was okay with we have skirted
around the legal question and I think
that that's fine I appreciate actually
the fact that bob has not been pressing
the league
argument and my only reason for bringing
up the Goldsmith's was because he did
sort of repeat that history that you
often hear where they first were taking
stuff and storing it and then they
started issuing more tickets and so on I
merely wish to say that's not what
actually happened in England at that
time but to close up to wrap up I think
we have to be more conscious of of the
the distorted view we have of banking
which has become more or less a an
account of all the disasters that have
happened in banking both in our own law
lifetimes and disasters we've heard
about in the past this is a looking at
the industry move through a distorted
lens
what people don't realize sometimes
because this doesn't make the newspapers
is the long history of successful stable
fractional reserve banking systems and
unfortunately because governments have
become more and more aggressive in their
interventions and regulations we are
less and less familiar with the
potential for stable fractional reserve
banking all the time and it's very sad
to find my myself debating what feels
like a dying institution for which I
have very positive feelings generally
but the real bottom line here that I'd
like to stress is this is an activity
that consenting adults have agreed to
engage in for hundreds of years that has
and that we know can produce desirable
results that does not necessarily result
in business cycles and indeed doesn't
contribute at all the business cycles as
long as we allow bankers to compete with
one another aggressively and check each
other's expansion as they will do in a
competitive system we should not blame
fractional reserve banking for problems
in the past or in the future that are
properly attributable not to that
institution itself but to the
interventions of governments especially
through central banking and through
other unwise banking regulations and I
feel that all the advocate
of 100% reserve banking have simply got
it wrong they have taken an institution
that is itself not unsound and that does
a lot of good and they have attributed
it
they have blamed it for problems that it
is not really to blame for it's rather
as if we decided that there were too
many traffic accidents on certain roads
and decided to ban automobiles without
recognizing that the problem was the
design of those roads or perhaps faulty
automobiles we have to decide whether
the institution itself is fundamentally
unsound and I think that the answer is
it is not unsound the historical facts
will simply not bear up the support the
argument that there's an inherent
problem of instability in fractional
reserve banks Thanks
[Applause]
George is very confident when he makes
assertions about the historical record
let me just point out two things that
were incredible admissions that came
from it just to say that you shouldn't
just the fact that he's very suave and
confident does not mean that his
statements about history are accurate it
just is a general rule especially if
you're in a club in New York City and
someone says something you and he's
suave and confident be very afraid okay
he he said they're here so for the of
course these are callable loans of
course these are this is a standard this
goes back hundreds of years and then he
said it is an offhand remark to me well
of course Mises didn't call it that
because he didn't have the terminology
available to him okay so I'm not saying
there was a necessarily contradiction
there but you see that the way he's now
describing it and saying this is what
everyone knew for hundreds of years
apparently as of 1949 Mises didn't have
that terminology available to him
because that practice hadn't developed
fully so I'm just saying that right
there there's there's some problem but
of course the humongous one he's sitting
here telling us the whole debate how
great the Scottish system was I mean
Adam Smith knows it you know what I know
what Bob Dole knows it everybody knows
how awesome the Scottish banking system
was and I asked him yeah I heard it was
X I looked up the date it was from 1797
to 1821 those are years or I'm not
talking about like at this time of day
and then next Tuesday it was from the
year 1797 to 1821 that the Scottish
banks didn't redeem in specie and he
said oh yeah that's true
and then he's lecturing and saying how
come they haven't offered these things
well of course if they're allowed to go
more than two decades without redeeming
it you'd be a sucker if you were Bank
playing by the rules and not doing that
and he even was saying yeah probably
wasn't even illegal and then he's a
believe it or not their customers were
relieved I don't believe it
alright so that no I don't think that
the customers were relieved that these
claims that they said you're allowed to
get gold and let banks said no you can't
come back in 25 years and maybe we'll
get some gold coin I don't think people
saying thank God I can't go to the bank
and get my coins back what a relief
so we're bad enough that friend she's
gonna just shoot me with his uh you know
troops
that's Napoleon reference listen
because he was French alright do I need
to talk about little Mexicans is that
what we need for that is that what this
is okay so now let me mention he said
that the free banking does not encourage
the boom-bust cycle let me just this is
from an expert in the free banking
literature so I agree with the claim
that a system of free banking does not
lead to the boom-bust cycle the way that
like ludwig von Mises and Friedrich
Hayek developed but this is but the
reason is it contains it okay so this
expert from the free banking literature
is quoting Mises from human action who
said issuance of fiduciary media and
fiduciary media are you know bank claims
on money the banks issue that are above
the hundred percent reserves so that
that's what we mean by fracture reserve
banking issuance of fiduciary media no
matter what its quantity may be always
sets in motion those changes in the
price structure the description of which
is the task of the theory of the trade
cycle okay so that's Mises real flowery
language and you know but missus is
saying any amount of issuance when banks
issue claims to money above and beyond
what they have on reserve sets in motion
the the boom-bust cycles he's described
it the next page now I'm still reading
from this writer this expert in the free
banking literature said indeed Mises
support for free banking is based in
part on his agreement with this other
economists who believe that freedom of
note issue would automatically lead to
100% reserve banking okay so there's
this this is expert is establishing that
yes Mises was for free banking and he
thought that would contain the business
cycle but because mark genuine market
forces would keep banks from keep from
having very low reserve ratios that the
reserve ratios will be pushed towards
100% reserves this author I'm quoting
from as you may have guessed is Georg
Celgene okay so this is not in dispute
Georg and I both agree that Mises who
developed the Austrian theory of the
business cycle of course was saying that
fractional reserve banking is that this
is the problem here okay so I'm not I'm
not appealing to Authority per se
although it doesn't help that Mises
agrees with me on this but what I'm
saying is be clear if you have thought
you liked the Austrian theory of the
business cycle and you said yeah there
is something there about when something
happens and I think artificially low
interest rate that the
people who develop that theory what they
had in mind was the banks commercial
banks expanding credit and contracting
it interest rates go low unsustainable
boom there's a problem they sucked the
credit out interest rates shoot up and
that's the crash all right so it was
developed in the context of the banking
system now I think George never really
disputed that per se his only real claim
was to say no no trust me historically
when we look back and look at the freest
most unregulated systems there's no
problems ok and so again but notice he
would if I hadn't brought it up I don't
think you would have walked out of here
knowing that the Scottish banks the
prime example suspended specie payments
for over 20 years ok and so yes that's
explains why you don't see a hard
percent reserve banking and it shows you
that there are crises that's inherently
destabilizing the results are as follows
bob was say it was it was arguing in
favor of the resolution the resolution
gotta got a yes vote of 46 percent
initially which rose to 55 percent Bob
picked up 9.4% points that's the number
to beat George started from the basement
at at a little under 15 percentage
points he went up to 20 a little over 29
percentage points so so George picked up
nearly 15 percentage points of George
gets the tootsie roll he went went up 50
percentage points to John to boat to
Bob's nine percentage points very close
but George gets the touchy well
you